[Music]
it's auntie Kelly spoiling the twins I
think that every child loves to be
spoils we have to stop spoiling my son
so much he gets pampers I mean I love
kids and I love the fact that you know
you don't want to spoil them you do want
to raise a great kid and that's
definitely a priority in my family I'm
not raising a brick at all you heard
Beyonce's new song with Eminem yeah
credible but I knew Jesus a porn star
part is amazing I was so I admire Eminem
so much because when I listen to his
song I was like oh it made me tear up
because it is a lot of pressure you know
what I mean that you want to make sure
that you deliver and give the absolute
best for your fans
my fans are mad at me now because it's
uncommon upon my fifth year I haven't
released music and they're like what is
wrong with you and it's it's so much
hesitation because you just want to give
them the best
so you'll second guess or like doubt
yourself but I'm happy that he's in a
space and I get this space and he's in
now like he's he's an animal and I'm
now so when I heard that record I was
like oh he's in his element he's an
animal
so yeah are you working on some music
sounds like urine I am I am I am you
have to be you have to be I'm very very
very
[Music]